cbs news analyst jill schlesinger is
here
can you help assistant with that you
know
a lot going on out there but the main
thing we all know is in three weeks
it's time to file our taxes yeah it is
and we'll be back to do like for the
super procrastinators i promise we'll do
a segment but for right now just know
file electronically choose your direct
deposit please make sure all your
numbers job and there are some resources
that people don't use you have a free
file system through the irs software and
filing if you make less than 73 000
bucks there is actually great resources
for
older people tax counseling for the
elderly the volunteer income tax
association as is of service for folks
who make less than 58 000
so these main points of assistance are
there for taxpayers use them if you have
any question just go to irs.gov lots of
info on the site you don't have to pay
for your return i wish more people took
advantage of those free services uh
whether you use a free service or an
accountant you got to gather documents
you get a return back a copy of it how
long you have to keep all that paperwork
i would like to dedicate this answer to
my mother susan
every single tax season how long do i
have to keep all this stuff so the irs
when they have an audit usually can look
back three years three years long time
but if they find a big error they can
tack on extra time so most experts say
keep returns and all supporting
documents for six
years
so oh six years
so the hoarder that i am and i've kept
all of that paperwork i'm afraid
yes you are okay but if it's beyonce you
don't want that audit coming that's
right but it but if it's beyond six
years you fire up the shredder and you
can get rid of everything shredder who
owns a shredder
no longer conversation
what are you shredding jill let me ask
you about there are some documents
though that you do need to keep forever
absolutely so birth and death
certificates social security i found
that out the hard way how so we're
getting married you need your you need
your birth certificate and mine was like
from the 60s i had to get like a you
know like i had it was a big deal yeah
so social security cards and you know
marriage licenses and divorce decrees
also military paperwork especially for
folks who want to make sure their
families have military burials sometimes
you need evidence of that but so that's
a given though vlad yeah i i i i don't
know where you're thinking you shouldn't
keep that stuff
like i'm sure my mom had it somewhere
okay all right next question a lot of
people focusing on the viewer again a
lot of people uh have a goal of paying
down debt right and like the question is
always simple how do you do that well it
takes money to do that if you've got
limited funds how do you allocate it to
pay that debt down you want to scour
what you are spending right now which
people hate i'm not saying you should be
on a budget michelle i'm not doing that
at all i am saying that you just look at
where you're spending and usually people
can find a little bit of of fudge factor
there some money that they can allocate
towards debt pay down next you want to
actually create a list and say okay what
is my highest interest debt right now
and go all the way down focus on the
highest interest debt i know there are
some people who are like oh i have a
little teeny tiny thing outstanding let
me just pay that off highest interest
first minimum payments on the rest then
shift down the list down down down and
you say it's a good time to check out
your credit score now too absolutely you
know over the last decade credit scores
have actually been improving in the
united states it's amazing so we were
below 700 10 years ago now we're at 7
14. what i think is important is that a
lot of people throughout the pandemic
paid down a lot of debt you want to make
sure that's reflected on your credit
report so annualcreditreport.com
you can get a free credit review every
12 months why are you looking at this
you want to make sure there's no errors
on that report if they see them you
correct them but also you want to make
sure that things that should be there
are there and it's reflected in your
score one other thing you can also flag
identity theft because if someone has
nefariously opened up credit in your
name you can see it on that report so
annualcreditreport.com the other thing
that comes up sometimes is you've paid
something off but it didn't show up it
wasn't removed from the report so it's
open credit even though it shouldn't be
that's exactly right so that's why we
want to look at that and just one other
word about shredding documents because i
know we were joking about this before we
came on the air that there are services
that will come to your house and do like
a massive shredding it's a great time to
do that right in front of you right in
front of you and please bank statements
and account statements you can keep them
for a year but if you have a family
where you think you're going to be
applying for medicaid like you think you
might need that there are a lot of
states that require five years of
investment and bank statements so be
careful before you go too crazy if you
want to save money you use the yard guy
with the leaves and he can do the paper
and the leaves at the same time throw it
all in i mean you got it i'm good for
the environment it's all spring for your
budget
it's great for the flowers they love it
jill slester thank you very much